castles are a universal fantasy but in
Irish castle hotel where you can try
medieval sports like falconry and then
sleep in rooms more plush and modern
than when the Guinness family owned them
yes that Guinness
now that's what we call a fantasy
getaway
set on 350 acres of woodland forest in
western ireland ashford castle has
evolved over its almost 800 years
everything is a little undulating so
it's a discovery for me I think it takes
one a month to get used to the place you
know there are so many alleyways and
some so many nooks and crannies the 82
room hotel just underwent some 26
million in gut renovations each room is
unique bespoke they all have their
different colors and there's no two
rooms the same it's so much easier to
have to clean the rooms because
everything is done you when everything's
painted there's a new cinema and a
billiards room with a peat fire place
the redone Georgia fifth restaurant is
as fantastic as when first built for the
Kings visit in 1906 dinner is a great
part of every day for us I just love
this room I love what we do here and the
food we produce here
unlike most hotels staff here keep on
for decades there's a lot of humor
involved in this a lot of quirkiness
we've had you the porter who's been here
for so many years if you mentioned Patti
the portrait anywhere people understand
and know that it's ashford castle
traditions thrive here proper
aristocratic activities like archery are
throwback there's also horseback riding
and fly fishing on Lough Corrib they are
even real Fox hunts it's one of the last
remaining actual hunts that you can
experience anywhere at the world but I
came for the falconry
neat Beckett he's a year and a half old
Harris Hawk and he's my hunting partner
for the day unlike peregrine falcons
which don't like strangers Harris Hawks
are the world's only social birds of
prey so this is the falconry glove and
it goes on your left arm to hold back it
you're gonna make a fist so he's gonna
take a step that's it today we're going
to be part of the pack we're going to be
the motivation to hunt you can't train a
bird of prey like a hunting dog they
won't fetch a kill but they will trade
it for a chicken foot hey nice flight
Beckett you can say to this bird if you
give me the big pheasant or that crow
that's kicking and screaming I'll give
you something easier to eat careful
though feed them too much and they'll
stop cooperating the term fed up that
comes from falconry as does being under
the thumb and hoodwinked and that's the
magic of ass room heritage links
comfortably to modern-day history keeps
on something keeps drawing you back I
don't what it is I love the place I
would just leave unless it's row me out
you